Democrats on the House Judiciary
Committee held a hearing Wednesday on
new gun control legislation that they
hope to push on the American people the
top Republican on the committee asked
Democrats if Congressman Steve Scalise
himself a victim of gun violence and a
proponent of Second Amendment rights
could testify about his unique
perspective
well Democrats denied him the
opportunity we reached out to the Senate
Judiciary Committee because it sounded
like it can't be true and we got a
comment back tonight now to their credit
they did respond saying the Republicans
chose two other witnesses other than
Scalise but Scalise is testimony's gonna
be entered into the record I mean Steve
Scalise wants to testify I spent 10
minutes let him testify here now is
Steve Scalise how do you respond to
their pushback on this narrative tonight
congressman yeah Laurie it was it was
pretty bizarre I mean historically when
Republicans were in charge even when
Democrats were in charge prior to this
more radical leftist majority if a
member of Congress wanted to testify on
a committee they always provided a venue
for that to happen and in this case they
were having a hearing in the judiciary
on reducing gun violence and I've got a
perspective clearly mine dealt with
something that happened to me and I saw
how guns were used to save people's
lives and it should have been able to be
part of the testimony they wanted to
focus on taking away the rights of
law-abiding citizens which their bill
ultimately does and so because my my
presentation would have been it would
have been very dramatic it would have
been extremely dramatic but my question
is and again everyone watching they
don't care about that house procedures
and it would have bogged down there well
why didn't Doug Collins a ranking member
insist that you go first
like if I'm the ranking member of
judiciary no one's stopping you from
testifying I don't know get what doug
collins did there who are these other
people testifying who are better than
you no one's better than you well yeah
like I mean ultimately he he wanted me
to be able to testify as well but in the
end I mean if the Democrats want to just
like Larry's about one thing about this
Nancy Pelosi tried to rescind the
president's ability to go give a
statement
playing they think they can silence
conservative voices but you know what
they can't silence our voice
I'm gonna get this message out anyway go
read their bill by the way HR 8 if you
loan your shotgun to a friend of yours
to go hunting under certain
circumstances in their bill you could
actually go to jail for a year and have
$100,000 fine and there say I want a
shotgun too if you roll your shotgun to
a friend to go hunting you go read their
bill their bill would under certain
circumstances actually allow that to be
a felony where you could get a year in
prison and a hundred thousand dollar
fines
basically if they think it was a if they
think was part of a gun transaction of
you selling you or you're gone or
loaning your gun to somebody else I mean
now that gun control is what they're
trying to get at they want full gun
registration they want to take away your
rights by the way if their bill would
have passed it would have done nothing
to stop the shooting that happened in my
case the shooting that happened in
parkland a lot of these other tragic
take away the rights of law-abiding
citizens to have a gun so they're trying
to hide behind you know we don't want
any rights taken away we want to limit
gun violence it's just the season by bit
it's about taking away your rights to
have a gun we're not we're gonna call
them out on it they're not gonna be able
to silence these voices so let them play
these charades and have kangaroo courts
but in the end the American people I
mean I know they think it's a winner
it's never a winner for them alright the
under God what explain this very quickly
I'm about a minute now Nadler went with
the was it the resource council Natural
Resources Committee and Democrats who
wanted the so help me God taken out of
swearing someone in so this is something
new that Democrats are doing in their
majority every House Committee sets
their own rules and the rules for
swearing a person in the Committee on
Natural Resources last week literally
tried to change the swearing in oath
that you take to remove the the phrase
so help me God take away Republicans on
the committee Garret graves and others
objected and they put it back in but
they tried to sneak it through so then
in the Judiciary Committee today they
tried to do the same thing that the
Natural Resources Committee did they
literally tried to take away the phrase
so help me God and again Republicans
call them out on it Mike Johnson in this
case called him out on it but these are
Democrats that are now chairing
committees this is Pelosi majority
so all those Democrat
- one saying they're pro-life pro-gun in
there against Pelosi they elect a Nancy
Pelosi as Speaker and now they're trying
to take away God they're trying to
silence voices they're trying to take
away your gun rights this is only in
their first month Laura now everybody
pay close attention what Donald Trump
did last night to lay the foundation for
what we need to do to get our country
back and to reject socialism and they
wouldn't even stand up again to reject
socialism that's where they're going if
they want to own socialism let them own
it all right congressman thank you so
much for joining us